The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so welcome
back to computational systems
biology, I'm David Gifford.
I'm delighted to be with
you here here today.
And today we're going to be
talking about a topic that
is central to modern high
throughput biology, which
is understanding how to do
short read alignment, sometimes
called read mapping.
Now it's very important
to me that you understand
what I'm about to
say today, and so I'm
hopeful that you'll be
uninhibited to raise your hand
and ask questions about the
fine points in today's lecture
if you have any, because I'd
be totally delighted to answer
any questions and we
have enough time today
that we can spend time looking
at one aspect of this problem
and understand it thoroughly.
An associated topic is the
question library complexity.
How many people have heard of
sequencing libraries before?
Let's see a show of hands.
OK, how many people have heard
of read alignment before, read
mapping?
OK, great, fantastic.
Let's start with
what we're going
to be talking about today.
We're going to first begin
talking about what a sequencing
library is and what we
mean by library complexity.
We'll then turn to what has been
called a full text minute size
index, sometimes called a
burrows Wheeler transform
index, a BWT index,
an FM index, but this
is at the center of most
modern computational biology
algorithms for processing high
throughput sequencing data.
And then we'll turn how
to use that type of index
for read alignment.
So let's start now with what
a sequencing library Is.
Let's just say that
you have a DNA sample,
we'll be talking about various
ways of producing said samples
throughout the term.
But we're going
to assume that we
have a bunch of
different DNA molecules.
And I'll illustrate the
different molecules here
in different colors.
And we have three different
types of molecules here.
Some molecules are duplicated,
because as you know,
typically, we're preparing DNA
from an experiment where there
are many cells and we can get
copies of DNA from those cells
or the DNA could
be amplified using
PCR or some other technique.
So we have this
collection of molecules,
and to make a library,
we're going to process it.
And one of the
things that we'll do
when we process the
library is we'll
put sequencing adapters on.
These are short DNA
sequences that we
put on to the end
of the molecules
to enable them to
have defined sequences
at the ends which
permits sequencing.
Now, if somebody hands you
a tube of DNA like this,
there are a couple
questions you could ask.
You could check the DNA
concentration to find out
how DNA is there,
you could run a gel
to look at the size
of the fragments
that you're sequencing.
We'll be returning
to that later,
but these are typically
called the insert sizes
of the library that
you're sequencing,
the total length of the
DNA excluding the adapters.
But we could also ask questions
about how complex this library
is, because it's possible to run
experiments where you produce
libraries that are
not very complex,
where they don't have very many
different types of molecules.
Now that typically is a
failure of the experiment.
So an important part
of quality control
is characterizing the
library complexity
where we want to figure out
here complexity is equal to 3.
There are three different
types of molecules.
And we sample these molecules.
And when we sample them, we get
a bunch of DNA sequence reads.
And typically the number
of reads that we get
is larger than the
complexity of the library.
Here we have a total
of 12 different reads.
And when we sequence a library,
we're sampling from it.
And so the probability that we
get any one particular molecule
is going to be roughly
speaking equal to 1
over c, which is the complexity.
And thus, we could use
the binomial distribution
to figure out the
likelihood that we
had exactly four of
these type one molecules.
However, as n the number
of sequencing reads
grows to be very large, typical
numbers are a hundred million
different reads,
the binomial becomes
cumbersome to work with.
And so we typically are
going to characterize
this kind of selection
process with a different kind
of distribution.
So one idea is to
use a Poisson, where
we say that the
rate of sequencing
is going to be n over c.
And we can see that
here shown on the slide
above is the same
process where we
have the ligation
of the adapters.
We have a library and we have
reads coming from the library.
We have a characterized
library complexity here,
there are four different
types of molecules.
And the modeling
approach is that assuming
that we have c different
unique molecules,
the probability that
we'll get any one of them
when we're doing the
sequencing is 1 over c.
And if we do end
sequencing reads,
we can find out the
probability that we'll
get a certain number of
each type of molecule.
Let's just stick with the
first one to start, OK?
Now part of the challenge
in analyzing sequencing data
is that you don't see
what you don't sequence.
So things that actually occur
0 times in your sequencing data
still may be present
in the library.
And what we would like to do
is from the observed sequencing
data, estimate the
library complexity.
So we have all of
the sequencing data,
we just don't know how
many different molecules
there are over here.
So one way to do
with this is to say
that let us suppose that we
make a histogram of the number
of times we see
distinct molecules
and we're going to say that
we can observe molecules that
are sequenced or appear l
times up through r times.
So we actually can
create a version
of the distribution
that characterizes
just a part of
what we're seeing.
So if we do this, we can
build a Poisson model
and we can estimate lambda
from what we can observe.
We don't get to observe
things we don't see.
So for sure, we know
we can't observe
the things that are
sequenced 0 times.
But for the things that are
sequenced at least one time,
we can build an
estimate of lambda.
And from that
estimate of lambda,
we can build an estimate of C.
So one way to look
at this is that if we
look at the total number
of unique molecules
that we sequence, which is
equal to m, then the probability
that we observe between l
and r occurrences of a given
individual sequence
times c is going
to be equal to the total
number of unique molecules
that we observe.
Another way to look at this
is the very bottom equation
where we note that if we
look at the total complexity
of the library and we multiply
it by 1 minus the probability
that we don't observe
certain molecules,
that will give an estimate
of the total number
of unique molecules
that we do see.
And thus we can
manipulate that to come up
with an estimate
of the complexity.
Are there any questions about
the details of this so far?
OK, so this is a
very simple model
for estimating the
complexity of a library based
upon looking at the
distribution of reads
that we actually observe for
quality control purposes.
And let us suppose that
we apply this to thousands
genomes data, which is
public data on human.
And suppose we want to test
whether this model works
or not, so what
we're going to do
is we're going to estimate
the library complexity from 10
percent of the sequencing
reads, so we'll
pick 10 percent of the reads
of an individual at random,
we'll estimate the
complexity of the library,
and then we'll also take all
of the region the individual
and estimate the complexity.
And if our estimator
is pretty good,
we should get about
the same number,
from 10 percent of the reads
and from all of the reads.
Will people go along with that?
Think that seems reasonable?
OK, so we do that.
And this is what we get.
And it's hard to see
the diagonal line here,
but there's a big oops here.
And the big oops is that if we
estimate the library complexity
from just 10 percent
of the reads,
it's grossly underestimating
the number of unique molecules
we actually have.
In fact, it's off by typically
a factor of two or more.
So for some reason,
even though we're
examining millions of
reads in this subsample,
we're not getting
a good estimate
of the complexity
of the library.
Does anybody have any idea
what could be going wrong here?
Why is it that this
very simple model that
is attempting to estimate how
many different molecules we
have here based upon what
we observe is broken?
Any ideas at all?
And please say your name first.
AUDIENCE: I'm Chris.
PROFESSOR: Hi Chris.
AUDIENCE: Is it because
repeated sequences,
so there could be a short
sequence at the end of one
molecule that's the beginning
of another one, middle
of another one, so [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Chris, you're
on the right track, OK?
Because what we have
assumed at the outset
was that all of these molecules
occur with equal probability.
Right?
What would happen
if in fact there
are four copies
of this purple one
and only two copies of
the other molecules?
Then the probability
of sampling this one
is going to be twice as high
as the probability of sampling
one of these.
If there's non uniformity
in the original population,
that's going to mess
up our model big time.
And that could happen
from repeated sequences
or other kinds of
duplicated things,
or it could be that there's
unequal amplification.
It might be that
PCR really loves
a particular molecule, right,
and amplifies that one a lot,
and doesn't amplify another one
that's difficult to amplify.
So somewhere in our
experimental protocol pipeline,
it could be that
there's non uniformity
and thus we're getting a
skewness to our distribution
here in our library.
So the other thing
that's true is
in a Poisson, lambda,
which is equal to the mean,
is also equal to the variance.
And so our Poisson's
only one knob
we could turn to fit
the distribution.
So coming back to this,
we talked about the idea
that the library complexity
still may be four
but then there may
be different numbers
of molecules of each type.
And here's an idea
for you, right?
The idea is this.
Imagine that the
top distributions
are the number of each type
of molecule that are present.
And it might be that our
original assumption was
that it was like the very
top, that typically there
are two copies of each molecule
in the original sequencing
library, and that's a
fairly tight distribution.
But it could be, in fact,
that the number of molecules
of each type is very dispersed.
And so if we look at
each one of those plots
at the top, the
first four, those
are going to be our guesses
about the distribution
of the number of
copies of a molecule
in the original library.
And we don't know
what that is, right?
That's something we can't
directly observe, but imagine
that we took that
distribution and used it
for lambda in our
Poisson distribution
down below for sampling.
So we have one distribution
over the number
of each type of
molecule we have and we
have the Poisson for
sampling from that,
and we put those two together.
And when we do that, we have
the Poisson distribution
at the top, the
gamma distribution
is what we'll use
for representing
the number of different
species over here
and their relative copy number.
And when we actually put
those together as shown,
we wind up with what's
called the negative binomial
distribution, which is a
more flexible distribution,
it has two parameters.
And that negative
binomial distribution
can be used, once again,
to estimate our library
complexity.
And when we do so, we
have lamba be the same,
but k is a new parameter.
It measures sort of the
variance or dispersion
of this original
sequencing library.
And then when we fit this
negative binomial distribution
to that 1,000 genomes data, it's
going to be hopefully better.
Let's start with
a smaller example.
If we have a library that's
artificial with a known million
unique molecules
and we subsample,
it gives you 100,000
reads, you can
see that with
different dispersions
here in the left, k
with different values
from 0.1 to 20, the Poisson
begins to grossly underestimate
the complexity of the library
as the dispersion gets larger,
whereas the negative
binomial, otherwise known
as the GP or gamma Poisson,
does a much better job.
And furthermore,
when we look at this,
in the context of the
thousand genomes data,
you can see when we fit this
how much better we are doing.
Almost all those points
are almost exactly
on the line, which means you
can take a small sampling run
and figure out from
that sampling run
how complex your library is.
And that allows us to tell
something very important, which
is what is the marginal
value of extra sequencing.
So for example, if somebody
comes to you and they say,
well, I ran my experiment
and all I could afford
was 50 million reads.
Do you think I
should sequence more?
Is there more information in my
experimental DNA preparation?
It's easy to tell now, right?
Because you can actually
analyze the distribution of the
reads that they got
and you can go back
and you could estimate
the marginal value
of additional sequencing.
And the way you do that is you
go back to the distribution
that you fit this
negative binomial
and ask if you
have r more reads,
how many more unique molecules
are you going to get?
And the answer is
that you can see
that if you imagine that
this is artificial data,
but if you imagine that
you had a complexity of 10
to the 6 molecules, the
number sequencing regions is
on the x-axis, the number of
observed distinct molecules
is on the y-axis, and as you
increase the sequencing depth,
you get more and more
back to the library.
However, the important thing
to note is that the more skewed
the library is, the less
benefit you get, right?
So if you look at the various
values of k, as k gets larger,
the sort of the
skewness of the library
increases, and you can see that
you get fewer unique molecules
as you increase the
sequencing depth.
Now I mention this
to you because it's
important to think
in a principled way
about analyzing sequencing data.
If somebody drops 200 million
reads on your desk and says,
can you help me with
these, it's good to start
with some fundamental
questions, like just how complex
is the original
library and you think
that these data are
really good or not, OK?
Furthermore, this is a
introduction to the idea
that certain kinds of
very simplistic models,
like Poisson models
of sequencing data
can be wrong because
they're not adequately
taking into account
the over dispersion
of the original
sequencing count data.
OK, so that's all there is
about library complexity.
Let's move on now to questions
of how to deal with these
reads once we have them.
So the fundamental
challenge is this.
I hand you a genome like human.
3 times 10 to the ninth bases.
This will be in fast
a format, let's say.
I had you reads.
And this will be-- we'll
have, say, 200 base
pairs times 2 times 10 to
the eighth different reads.
And this will be
in fast q format.
The q means that there are--
it's like fast a except
that our quality
score's associated
with each particular
base position.
And the PHRED score
which is typically
used for these
sorts of qualities,
is minus p minus 10
times log base 10
of the probability of an error.
Right, so a PHRED score of
10 means that there's a 1
in 10 chance that the bases is
an error, a PHRED score of 20
means it's one in a
100, and so forth.
And then the goal is
today if I give you
these data on a
hard drive, your job
would be to produce a SAM
file, a Sequence Alignment
and Mapping file,
which tells us where
all these reads
map in the genome.
And more pictorially,
the idea is
that there are many
different reasons why
we want to do this mapping.
So one might be
to do genotyping.
You and I differ in our
genomes by about one base
in a thousand.
So if I sequence your genome
and I map it back or align it
to the human brain
reference genome,
I'm going to find differences
between your genome
and the human reference genome.
And you can see how this is
done at the very top where
we have the aligned
reads and there's a G,
let's say, in the
sample DNA, and there's
a C in the reference.
But in order to figure out
where the differences are,
we have to take
those short reads
and align them to the genome.
Another kind of
experimental protocol
uses DNA fragments
that are representative
of some kind of
biological process.
So here the DNA being
produced are mapped back
to the genome to look
for areas of enrichment
or what are sometimes
called peaks.
And there we want to actually
do exactly the same process,
but the post processing once
the alignment is complete
is different.
So both of these share the goal
of taking hundreds of millions
of short reads and aligning
them to a very large genome.
And you heard about Smith
Waterman from Professor Berg,
and as you can tell, that
really isn't going to work,
because its time
complexity is not
going to be admissible for
hundreds of millions of reads.
So we need to come up
with a different way
of approaching this problem.
So finding this alignment is
really a performance bottleneck
for many computational
biology problems today.
And we have to talk a
little bit about what
we mean by a good alignment,
because we're going to assume,
of course, fewer
mismatches are better.
And we're going to try and
align to high quality bases
as opposed to low quality
bases and note that all we
have in our input data are
quality scores for the reads.
So we begin with an assumption
that the genome is the truth
and when we are
aligning, we are going
to be more permissive
of mismatches
in read locations that have
higher likelihood of being
wrong.
So is everybody OK
with the set up so far?
You understand what
the problem is?
Yes, all the way in the back
row, my back row consultants,
you're good on that?
See, the back row
is always the people
I call on for consulting
advice, right?
So yeah.
You're all good back there?
Good, I like that, good,
that's good, I like that, OK.
All right.
So now I'm going to
talk to you about what
are the most amazing
transforms I have seen.
It's called the Burrows
Wheeler Transform.
And it is a transform
that we will
do to the original
genome that allows
us to do this look up
very, very quickly.
And it's worth understanding.
So here's the basic idea behind
the Burrows Wheeler Transform.
We take the original string that
we want to use as our target
that we're going to
look things up in, OK,
so this is going to be the
dictionary looking things up in
and it's going to be
the genome sequence.
And you can see the sequence on
the left hand side, ACA, ACG,
and the dollar sign represents
the end of string terminator.
OK.
Now here's what
we're going to do.
We take all possible
rotations of this string, OK?
And we're going to sort them.
And the result of
sorting all the rotations
is shown in the next
block of characters.
And you can see that the
end of string character
has the shortest sorting
order, followed by A, C, and G
and that all the strings
are ordered lexically
by all of their letters.
So once again, we take
the original input string,
we do all of the
possible rotations of it,
and then we sort them and wind
up with this Burrows Wheeler
Matrix as it's called
in this slide, OK?
And we take the last
column of that matrix
and that is the Burrows
Wheeler Transform.
Now yo might say, what on
earth is going on here?
Why would you want to
take a string or even
an entire genome?
We actually do this
on entire genomes, OK?
Consider all the
rotations of it,
sort them, and then take the
last column of that matrix.
What could that be doing, OK?
Here's a bit of
intuition for you.
The intuition is that that
Burrows Wheeler Matrix
is representing all
of the suffixes of t.
OK, so all the red things are
suffixes of t in the matrix.
And when we are going
to be matching a read,
we're going to be matched
it from its end going
towards the beginning
of it, so we'll
be matching suffixes of it.
And I'm going to show you a
very neat way of using this
transform to do matching
very efficiently.
But before I do that,
I want you to observe
that it's not complicated.
All we do is we take all
the possible rotations
and we sort them and we
come up with this transform.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What are you
sorting them based on?
PROFESSOR: OK, what
was your name again?
AUDIENCE: I'm Samona.
PROFESSOR: Samona.
What are we sorting
them based upon?
We're just sorting
them alphabetically.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So you can see that
if dollar sign is the lowest
alphabetical character,
that if you consider
each one a word, that they're
sorted alphabetically, OK?
So we have seven
characters in each row
and we sort them alphabetically.
Or a lexically.
Good question.
Any other questions like that?
This is a great time
to ask questions,
because what's
going to happen is
that in about the
next three minutes
if you lose your attention
span of about 10 seconds,
you're going to look up and
you'll say, what just happened?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
explain the suffixes of t?
PROFESSOR: The suffixes of t?
Sure.
Let's talk about
the suffixes of tr.
They're all of the
things that end t.
So a suffix of t would be
G, or CG, or ACG, or AACG,
or CAACG, or the
entire string t.
Those are all of
the endings of t.
And if you look
over on the right,
you can see all of
those suffixes in red.
So one way to
think about this is
that it's sorting all of the
suffixes of t in that matrix.
Because the rotations are
exposing the suffixes,
right, is what's going on.
Does that make sense to you?
Now keep me honest here in a
minute, OK, you'll help me out?
Yes.
Your name first?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: What is dollar sign?
PROFESSOR: Dollar sign is
the end of string character
which has the lowest
lexical sorting order.
So it's marking the end of t.
That's how we know that
we're at the end of t.
Good question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you sort them
non-alphabetically, just
different ways to sort
them [INAUDIBLE] algorithm?
PROFESSOR: The
question is, can you
sort them non alphabetically.
You can sort them any way as
long as it's consistent, OK.
But let's stick with
alphabetical lexical order
today.
It's really simple
and it's all you need.
Yes.
in red is the suffixes
in the last colored
group on the right?
PROFESSOR: No, no.
AUDIENCE: What's in red?
PROFESSOR: What's in
red are all the suffixes
of T on the very far left.
OK?
AUDIENCE: On the right,
last column group?
PROFESSOR: The right
last column group.
That last column in red, that is
the Burrows-Wheeler Transform,
read from top to bottom.
OK?
And I know you're
looking at that
and saying, how could
that possibly be useful?
We've taken our genome.
We've shifted it all around.
We've sorted it, we
take this last thing.
It looks like junk to me, right?
But you're going to
find out that all
of the information in
the genome is contained
in that last string
in a very handy way.
Hard to believe but true.
Yes.
Prepare to be amazed, all right?
These are all great questions.
Any other questions
of this sort?
.
OK.
So, I'm going to make a very
important observation here
that is going to be crucial
for your understanding.
So I have reproduced the
matrix down on this blackboard.
What?
That's usually there under
that board, you know that.
You guys haven't checked this
classroom before, have you?
No.
It's always there.
It's such a handy transform.
So this is the same
matrix as the matrix
you see on the right.
I'm going to make a very, very
important assertion right now.
OK?
The very important assertion
is that if you consider
that this is the first a
in the last column that
is the same textual occurrence
in the string as the first a
in the first column.
And this is the second a
in the last column, that's
the same as the second
a in the first column.
And you're going to say,
what does he mean by that?
OK, do the following
thought experiment.
Look at the matrix.
OK?
And in your mind, shift it
left and put all the characters
on the right hand side.
OK?
When you do that,
what will happen
is that these
things will be used
to sort the occurrences
a on the right hand side.
Once again, if you shift this
whole thing left and these pop
over to the right, then the
occurrence of these a's will
be sorted by these
rows from here over.
But these are alphabetical.
And therefore they're going
to certain alphabetical order.
And therefore these a's
will sort in the same order
here as they are over there.
So that means that when
we do this rotation,
that this textual
occurrence of a will
have the same rank in the first
column and in the last column.
And you can see I've annotated
the various bases here
with their ranks.
This is the first g, the first
c, the first end of line,
end of string character.
First a, second a,
third a, second c.
And correspondingly I
have the same annotations
over here and thus
the third a here is
the same lexical occurrence
as the third a on the left
in the string, same
text occurrence.
Now I'm going to let that
sink in for a second,
and then when somebody
asks a question,
I'm going to explain it again
because it's a little bit
counterintuitive.
But the very important
thing is if we
think about textual recurrences
of characters in that string t
and we put them
in this framework,
that the rank allows
us to identify
identical textual
recurrences of a character.
Would somebody like
to ask a question?
Yes.
Say your name and
the question, please.
AUDIENCE: Dan.
PROFESSOR: Dan.
AUDIENCE: So in
your original string
though those won't
correspond to the same order
in the transformed string.
So like the a's in the
original string in their order,
they don't correspond
numerically
to the transformed string.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
Is that OK?
The comment was that the
order in BWT, the transform
is not the same as the order
in the original string.
And all I'm saying is that in
this particular matrix form,
that the order on
the last column
is the same as the order
in the first column
for a particular character.
And furthermore, that these are
matching textual occurrences,
right?
Now if I look at
a2 here, we know
that c comes after it, then
a, then a, and c and g, right?
Right.
OK, so did that
answer your question
that they're not
exactly the same?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I don't understand how
they're useful yet.
PROFESSOR: You don't
understand how it's useful yet.
OK.
Well, maybe we better
get to the useful part
and then you can-- OK.
So let us suppose that
we want to, from this,
reconstruct the original string.
Does anybody have any
ideas about how to do that?
OK.
Let me ask a different question.
If we look at this g1, right?
And then this is the same
textual occurrence, right?
And we know that
this g1 comes right
before the end of character,
in end of string terminator,
right?
So if we look at the
first row, we always
know what the last character
was in the original string.
The last character is g1, right?
Fair enough?
OK
Where does g1 would
occur over here?
Right over here, right?
What's the character before g1?
c2.
where is c2 over here?
What's the character before c2?
a3.
What's the character before a3?
a1.
Uh, oh.
Let me just cheat a little
bit here. a1 a3 c2 g1 $.
So we're at a1, right?
What's the character before a1?
c1, right?
What's the character before c1?
a2.
And what's the
character before a2?
That's the end of string.
Is that the original
string that we had?
Magic.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't it
be simpler to look at--
to just remove the
dollar sign [INAUDIBLE]
or do you mean reconstruct
from only the transformed?
PROFESSOR: We're
only using this.
This is all we have.
Because I actually didn't
use any of these characters.
I was only doing the matching
so we would go to the right row.
Right?
I didn't use any of this.
And so, but do people
understand what's going on here?
If anybody has any questions,
now is a great time
to raise your hand
and say-- here we go.
We have a customer.
Say your name and
the question, please.
AUDIENCE: My name is Eric.
PROFESSOR: Thanks, Eric.
AUDIENCE: Can you illustrate
how you would do this
without using any
of the elements
to the left of the box?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely, Eric.
I'm so glad you
asked that question.
That's the next thing
we're going to talk about.
OK, but before I get to
there, I want to make sure,
are you comfortable doing
it with all the stuff
on the left hand side?
You're happy about that?
OK. if anyone was unhappy about
that, now would be the time
to say, I'm unhappy, help me.
How about the details?
Everybody's happy?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, you have
your original string
in the first place,
though, so why
do you want to create another
string of the same length?
Like, how does this help
you match your read?
PROFESSOR: How does this
help you match your read?
How does this help you match
your read, was the question.
What is was your name?
AUDIENCE: Dan.
PROFESSOR: That's right, Dan.
That's a great question.
I'm so glad you asked it.
First we'll get
to Eric's question
and then we'll get to yours.
Because I know if I don't give
you a good answer that you're
going to be very mad, right?
OK?
Let's talk about
the question of how
to do this without
the other things.
So we're going to create
something called the last
to first function that maps
a character in the last row,
column, I should say,
to the first column.
And there is the
function right there.
It's called LF.
You give it a row number.
The rows are zero origined.
And you give it a
character and it tells you
what the corresponding place
is in the first column.
And it has two components.
The first is Occ, which tells
you how many characters are
smaller than that
character lexically.
So tells you where, for example,
the a's start, the c's start,
or the g's start.
So in this case, for
example Occ of c is 4.
That is the c's start at
0, 1,2, 3, the fourth row.
OK?
And then count tells you
the rank of c minus 1.
So it's going to
essentially count
how many times c occurs
before the c at the row you're
pointing at.
In this case, the
answer is 1 and you
add 1 and that gets you
to 5, which is this row.
So this c2 maps here to c2
as we already discussed.
So this LF function is a
way to map from the last row
to the first row.
And we need to have
two components.
So we need to know Occ, which
is very trivial to compute.
There are only five
elements, one for each base
and one for the end of line
terminator, which is actually
zero.
So it will only have
integers and count, which
is going to tell us the
rank in the BWT transform
and we'll talk about how
to do that presently.
OK.
So did that answer
your question,
how to do this without
the rest of the matrix?
Eric?
AUDIENCE: Could you show us
step by step on the blackboard
how you would reconstruct it?
PROFESSOR: How do
we reconstruct it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: You mean
something like this?
Is this what you're suggesting?
AUDIENCE: Somehow
I get a feeling
that the first column
doesn't help us
in understanding how
the algorithm work only
using the last column.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Your comment, Eric,
is that you feel
like the first column
doesn't help us understand
how the algorithm works, only
using the last column, right?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] going back
to the first column of data.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well let's compute the LF
function of the character
and the row for each
one of these things, OK?
And that might help
you, all right?
Because that's the central part
of being able to reverse this
transform.
So this is, to be more clear,
I'll make it more explicit.
This is LF of I and BWT of
i, where i goes from 0 to 6.
So what is that value
for this one right here?
Anybody know?
Well it would be Occ of
g, which is 6, right?
Plus count of of 6 n g,
which is going to be 0.
Or I can look right
over here and see
that in fact it's 6, right?
Because this occurrence
of g1 is right here.
So this LF value is, it's 6
4 0 a1 is in 1, a2 is in 2,
a3 is in 3, c2 is in 5.
So this is the LF
function, 6 4 0 1 2 3 5.
And I don't need any
of this to compute it.
Because it simply is equal
to, going back one slide,
it's equal to Occ
of c plus count.
So it' going to be equal to
where that particular character
starts on the left hand
side and its rank minus 1.
And so these are
the values for LF.
This is what I need to be
able to take this string
and recompute the
original string.
If I can compute this, I
don't need any of that.
And to compute this,
I need two things.
I need Occ and I need count.
All right?
Now, I can tell you're not
quite completely satisfied yet.
So maybe you can ask
me another question
and it would be
very helpful to me.
AUDIENCE: How did you get
G1's last and first functions
score being 6?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's take that apart.
We want to know what LF of
6 and where was that G1?
G1 is 1 and 0, right?
Sorry.
LF of 1 and g is
equal to, right?
Is that g and 1 or 0?
Oop, sorry it's in 0.
So this is what you like
me to compute, right?
OK what's Occ of g?
It's how many characters
are less than g
in the original string?
I'll give you a clue.
It's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, it's how many
characters are less than g
in the original string.
How many things are going
to distort underneath it?
Where do the g's begin
in the sorted version?
The g's begin in row 6.
OK?
So OCC of g is 6.
Is that-- are you getting
hung up on that point?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
How do you know that without
ever referencing back
to the first 5 columns?
PROFESSOR: Because when we
build the index we remember.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: So we have to,
I haven't told you this,
but I need to compute,
I need to remember
ways to compute Occ and
count really quickly.
Occ is represented
by four values only.
They're where the a's start,
the c's start, the t's start,
and the g's start.
That's all I need to
know, four integers.
OK?
Are you happy with that?
Occ, the a's start at 1.
The c's start at 4 and
the g's start at 6.
OK?
That's all I need to remember.
But I precompute that.
OK?
Remember it.
Are you happy with that no?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then this business over
here of count of zero and g.
Right?
Which is how many
g's, what's the rank
of this g in the
right hand side?
1.
Minus 1 is 0.
So that's 0.
That's how we computed it.
OK?
These are great
questions because I
think they're foundational.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Occ and count
are both precomputed
as you're building on this
last column [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: They are
precomputed and well,
I have not told you, see,
you're sort of ahead of things
a little bit in that I'd
hoped to suspend disbelief
and that I could actually
build these very efficiently.
But yes, they're
built at the same time
as the index is built.
OK?
But yes.
OK and if I have Occ and
count and I have the string,
then I can get this.
But I can still need to
get to Dan's question
because he has been
very patient over there.
He wants to know
how I can use this
to find sequence
region of genome.
And he's just being
so good over there.
I really appreciate that, Dan.
Thanks so much for that.
Are you happier?
OK you're good.
All right.
So and this is what we just did.
The walk left algorithm
actually inverts the BWT
by using this
function to walk left
and using that
Python code up there,
you can actually reconstruct
the original string
you started with.
So it's just very simple.
And we went through
it on the board.
Are there any questions
about it at all?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Can you actually
do this any column?
Like, why are you using the
last column instead of like,
why can't you just change
it like the [INAUDIBLE],
the equation and
make it work for--
PROFESSOR: Because a
very important thing
is that this is actually a
very important property right?
Which is all the
suffixes are sorted here.
And if we didn't
do that though, I
couldn't answer Dan's question.
And he'd be very upset.
So please be respectful
of his interest here.
Now, the thing is,
the beauty of this
is, is that I have all
these suffixes sorted
and what you're about to see is
the most amazing thing, which
is that we're going
to snap our fingers
and, bang, we can
map 200 million reads
in no time at all.
You like that?
You're laughing.
Oh, oh, that's not a good
That's not a good sign.
Let's press ahead
fearlessly, OK?
And talk about how we're
going to use this to map read.
So we're going to
figure out how to use
this index and this
transform to rapidly aligned
reads to a reference genome.
And we're not talking about
one read or 10 reads or 1
million reads.
We're talking about hundreds
of millions of reads.
So it has be very
efficient indeed, OK?
So here's the essential idea.
There's the core
algorithm on the slide.
Which is that what we do is we
take the original query that we
have the read that
we're trying to match
and we're going to
process it backwards
from the end of
the read forwards.
And we begin by considering all
possible suffixes from row zero
to, in this case, it
would be row seven.
Which is the length of
the entire transform.
And we iterate and
in each iteration
we consider suffixes
that match the query.
So in the first
step, right here,
let me see if I can get my
point working, there we are.
So in the first step
here, we matching this c.
OK?
And we compute the
LF of the top, which
is this row and of the bottom,
which is down here pointing off
the end, and that takes
us to the first d here
and to this point.
Here are the two
c's that could be
possible matches to our
query, which ends in a c.
We then say, oh, the next
character we have to match
is an a.
So we look here at the
a we need to match,
and starting from this
row, which is row four,
and this row, which is row six,
we compute the LF of each one
of these to figure out what
rows in a precedes these c's.
And the way we compute the LF
is that we use the character a
to be able to figure out which
rows have the a preceding
the c.
You can see, when we
compute those LF functions,
what we wind up with
are these rows where
we have a followed by c.
So we're beginning to
match the end of our read,
as we go from right to left.
We then compute the
same thing once again,
considering the
first a and ask what
rows are going to allow us to
put this a in front of the ac
to form our entire read.
And we compute the LF once
again of these things.
And you can see that
here it takes us
to this specific row aac.
So that row represents
a suffix that
is matching our query exactly.
So we iterate this loop
to be able to match
a read against the index.
And we're using the
LF function to do it.
And it's a really
beautiful algorithm.
And remember, we only
have the transform.
We don't have the
rest of this matrix.
So before I press ahead and
talk about other details,
I think it's important to
observe a couple of things that
are a little bit
counterintuitive about this.
One counterintuitive
aspect of it
is, that when I'm over here
for example, and for example
when I'm computing the LF here,
I'm computing the LF of row two
with respect to a.
But there's a dollar sign there.
Right?
So I'm using this
to the LF function,
to tell me where a suffix
would be that actually follows
my constraint of having to
have an a be the prefix of ac,
where I am right now.
This code is actually
not fake code.
It's the actual code
that's in a matcher,
for matching a read
against the index.
Now let me just stop
right here for a second
and see if there
any other questions.
Dan is getting now his answer
to his question, right?
About how you actually use
this for matching reads.
You do this once for every read.
And it is linear time.
Right?
It's the length
of the read itself
is all the time it takes
to match in a huge genome.
So once we've built the
index of the genome,
in fact, most of
the time when you're
doing this sort of mapping,
you don't build the index.
You download the index
off of a website.
And so you don't have to pay for
the time to build this index.
You just download the index
and you take your reads
and the time to match
all of your sequencing
reads against a certain build
of whatever genome you're using
is simply linear in the
number of bases you have.
Questions?
Yes.
And say your name and
the question, please.
AUDIENCE: How did
[INAUDIBLE] come up
with intuition [INAUDIBLE]?
It seems like they just
pulled it out of a hat.
PROFESSOR: You know, I asked
Mike that the other day.
I saw him in a meeting
and he sort of surprised
at how this has taken off.
And he told me some
other interesting facts
about this, which you
probably could deduce.
Which is that if you
only want to match
reads that are
four long, you only
have to sort this matrix by
the first four characters.
But there are other little
tricks you can play here.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm Deborah.
What is the FM index?
PROFESSOR: What is the FM index.
Well, the guys who
thought this up
have the last
initials of F and M,
but that's not
what it stands for,
contrary to popular opinion.
It stands for full
text minute size.
That's what they claim.
So if you hear people talking
about full text minute size
indices, or FM
indices, the Fm index
is actually the part that was
being asked over here, the Occ
part and the LF part, how you
actually compute those quickly.
That was what FNM contributed
to this but, generically when
we're talking about
this style of indexing,
it's called FM indexing or you
might hear, I'm using a BWT.
Some people will say that.
But that's what FM stands for.
Does that answer your question?
Excellent.
OK.
All right.
Any-- these are all
great questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, you
don't know that a
and c are there,
except that remember,
if you look at the way
that this is working,
is that you're not actually
reconstructing strings,
you're only trying to find them.
Right?
And so at the end,
top and bottom
are going to point to the row
that contains the suffix where
your original read was.
And now your next
question is going to be,
where is that in the genome?
This doesn't do me any good.
I mean, the number 1
doesn't help me out here,
doesn't mean anything.
Not good, right?
So where is it in the
genome is the next question.
So we'll get to
that in a second.
What happens if you
give me a read that
doesn't match anywhere
in this index?
Well if you give me a read
that doesn't match anywhere
in this index, what happens
is the top and bottom
become the same.
So on top and bottom become the
same, it's a failed look up.
All right?
And that's because the suffix
doesn't exist in the index.
And once top and
bottom become the same,
they remain the same
throughout that loop.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm Sally.
My main question is
that this doesn't
provide any leeway for errors.
You kind of have to be able
to present all of your rates.
PROFESSOR: Sally, you're
absolutely correct.
I'm so glad you
asked that question.
Your observation is
it does not provide
any leeway for mismatches.
And so unlike all the
other algorithms we study,
which had these very
nice matrices and ability
to assign weights
to mismatches, this
is only doing exact matching.
And so what you need
help understanding
is, how we can deal
with mismatches
in the presence of this.
And I'll get to that in
less than 10 minutes.
And it won't be quite as elegant
as what you saw from Professor
Berg but it's what
everybody does.
So that's my only
excuse for it OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is the
bottom set of arrows doing?
What's its significance?
PROFESSOR: The significance
of top and bottom,
that's a great question.
What the significance
of top and bottom?
Top and bottom bracket
in that original matrix,
the suffixes that are
matching the original query.
OK?
And so between top
and bottom minus 1
are all of the rows
that have a suffix that
match our original query.
And if top equals bottom,
there are no matching suffixes.
But assuming there
are matching suffixes,
those are rows that
contain a matching suffix.
And as we progress along,
top and bottom change
as the suffixes change
as we expand the suffix
to contain more and more bases.
OK?
OK.
Any other questions?
So now back to the question
over here, which is that OK,
I know that we've matched, and
I know that we have this hit.
The question is, where is it
in the Genome because the fact
that it matched row
one of my BWT matrix
does me absolutely
no good at all.
Right?
Anybody have any ideas about
how we could figure out
where it is the genome?
Given what I've told you so far,
which is that you have the BWT,
you have Occ, and
you have count,
and you can compute
the LF function.
Any ideas?
Doesn't matter how slow it is.
OK well how could
I figure out what
came before aac in the genome?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, for,
like at the beginning,
we rebuilt this whole
string, starting at the end.
You could rebuild the
whole string starting at,
rebuild the whole genome
starting at the 1 and see--
PROFESSOR: You could rebuild
the entire genome that
prepends or occurs
before aac, right?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So that's what we can do.
We could actually do
our walk left algorithm.
We can walk left
from there, find out
that we go two steps
until we hit dollar sign,
and therefore,
the offset is two,
where it occurs in the genome.
So we can give a match
position by walking left.
Does everybody see
that, that we could
walk left to figure where it is?
It's not fast, but it works.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm Ted.
PROFESSOR: Hi, Ted.
AUDIENCE: So now our function
first has to take the read
and it has to align
it and the same,
where the position is built
into the end of the function,
the speed of the function is now
dependent on position as well.
Is that right?
Because the longer it takes,
PROFESSOR: I was
being a little bit
glib find if it matches
or not this linear time.
Now you're saying,
hey, wait a minute.
I want to know where
it is in the genome.
That's a big bonus, right?
And so you'd like to
know where that is?
Yes.
But I still can do
that in linear time.
And we'll show you how
to do that in a second.
This is not linear time.
This actually
needs to walk back,
order the length of genome
for every single query.
That's not good.
All right?
Well,
What we could do is, we could
store what's called a suffix
array with each row and
say, where in the genome
that position is.
Where that row starts.
And then maybe a simple look-up.
That when you actually have
a hit in row one, ah, OK,
start your position
two of the genome.
But then the
problem with that is
that it actually
takes a lot of space.
And we want to have
compact indices.
So the trick is what we
do is, instead of storing
that entire suffix
array, we store
every so many rows,
like every 25 rows.
And all we do is, we
walk left until we
hit a row that
actually has the value,
and then we add how many times
we walked left, plus the value
and we know where we
are in the genome.
So we can sample
the suffix array,
and by sampling
we cut down our storage
hugely and it's still
pretty efficient.
Because what we
can do is, we just
walk left until we hit a
sample suffix array location
and then add the two
numbers together.
All right?
So that's how it's done.
OK?
So that's how we
actually do the alignment
and figure out where things are.
The one thing I
haven't told you about
is how to compute
count efficiently.
Now remember what count does.
Count is a function--
but this is putting it
all together where we're
matching this query,
we do the steps.
We get the match.
Then we do walk
left once and then
we look at the suffix to
figure out where we are, right?
The business about count
is that what we need to do
is to figure out the
rank of a particular base
in a position in the transform.
And one way to do that is
to go backwards to the whole
transform, counting how many
g;s occur before this one,
and that's very expensive,
to compute the rank of this
particular g.
Remember the rank is simply
the number of g's that
occur before this
one in the BWT.
Very simple metric.
So instead of
doing that, what we
can do is, we can build a
data structure that every once
in awhile, counts how
many a's, c's, g's,
and t's have occurred
before now in the BWT.
And so we're going to sample
this with these checkpoints,
and then when you want to
compute count at any point,
you can go to the nearest
checkpoint, wherever that is,
and make an
adjustment by counting
the number of characters
between you and that checkpoint.
Very straightforward.
All Right
So this, coming back to
question, it's Time, right?
--asked you need to
build this checkpointing
mechanism at the same time you
build the index, as well as
the sampling of
the suffix array.
So a full index consists
of the transform
itself, which is the genome
transformed into its BWT.
And they literally take the
entire genome and do this.
Typically they'll put dollar
signs between the chromosomes.
So they'll transform
the whole thing.
It takes a sampling
of the suffix array
we just saw and it takes
the checkpointing of the LF
function to make
a constant time.
And that's what is
inside of an FM index.
OK?
Now it's small, which is
one of the nice things,
compared to things
like suffix tree,
suffix arrays, or even other
kinds of hash structures
for looking for seeds, it
really is not even twice
the size of the genome.
So it's a very compact index
that is very, very efficient.
And so it's a wonderful
data structure
for doing what we're
doing, except we have not
dealt with mismatches
yet, right?
And so once again,
I want to put a plug
in for BWA which is really
a marvelous aligner.
And we'll talk about
tomorrow in recitation
if you want to know all of the
details of what it actually
takes to make this
work in practice.
Now, it finds exactness
matches quickly,
but it doesn't really have
any allowances for mismatches.
And the way that bow tie and
other aligners deal with this,
and they're all
pretty consistent,
is in the following way, which
is that they do backtracking.
Here's the idea.
You try and match
something or match a read
and you get to a particular
point in the read,
and you can't go any further.
Top is equal to bottom.
So you know that
there's no suffix
in the genome that
matches your query.
So what do you do?
Well, what you can do is you can
try all of the different bases
at that position
besides the one you
tried to see whether
it matches or not.
I can see the horror
coming over people.
Oh, no, not
backtracking, not that.
But sometimes it actually works.
And just to give you order of
magnitude idea about how this
works in practice,
when reads don't match,
they limit backtracking to about
125 times in these aligners.
so they try pretty hard
to actually match things.
And yes, it is true that
even with this backtracking,
it's still a great approach.
And sometimes the first
thing you try doesn't work,
and you have to backtrack,
trying multiple bases
at that location until
you get one that matches.
And then you can proceed.
OK And you eventually
wind up at the alignment
you see in the lower right
hand corner, where you're
substituting a g for an a,
an a for a g, excuse me,
to make it go forward.
Do people understand
the essential idea
of this idea of backtracking?
Does anybody have any comments
or questions about it?
Like ew, or ideas?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What about gaps?
PROFESSOR: What about gaps?
BWA, I believe, processes gaps.
But gaps are much, much less
likely than missed bases.
The other thing is that if
you're doing a sequencing
library, and you have a read
that actually has a gap in it,
it's probably the case you
have another read that doesn't.
For the same sequence.
So it is less important
to process gaps
than it is to
process differences.
The reason is that
differences mean
that it might be a
difference of an allele.
In other words, it
might be that your base
is different than
the reference genome.
Indels are also possible.
And there are
different strategies
of dealing with those.
That would be a great question
for Hang tomorrow about gaps.
Because he can tell you
in practice what they do.
And we'll get into
a little bit of that
at the end of today's lecture.
Yes.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I'm Levy.
PROFESSOR: Hi, Levy.
AUDIENCE: How do
you make sure when
you're backtracking
that you end up
with the best possible match?
Do you just go down the first--
PROFESSOR: The
questions is how do you
guarantee you wind up with
the best possible match?
The short answer
is that you don't.
There's a longer
answer, which we're
about to get to, about how
we try to approximate that.
And what judgment you would use
to get to what we would think
is a practically good match.
OK?
But in terms of
theoretically optimal,
the answer is, it doesn't
attempt to do that.
That's a good question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In practice, does
this backtracking method
at the same time as you're
computing the matches or--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So what's happening is,
you remember that loop
where we're going
around, where we
were moving the top
and bottom pointers.
If you get to a point
where they come together,
then you would at that
point, begin backtracking
and try different bases.
And if you look, I
posted the BWA paper
on the Stellar website.
And if you look in
one of the figures,
the algorithm is there,
And you'll actually
see, if you can deconvolute
what's going on,
that inside the loop, it's
actually doing exactly that.
Yes.
Question.
AUDIENCE: In practice, is the
number of errors is small,
would it make sense
just to use [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: We're
going to get to that.
I think the question was, if
the number of errors is small,
would it be good to actually
use a different algorithm,
drop into a different algorithm?
So there are algorithms
on FM index assisted
Smith Waterman, for example.
Where you get to
the neighborhood
by a fast technique and
then you do a full search,
using a more in depth
principles methodology, right?
And so there's some papers
I have in the slides here
that I referenced
that do exactly that.
These are all great questions.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If you're-- If
you only decide to backtrack
a certain number of
times, like 100 times,
then wouldn't like the alignment
be biased towards the end
of the short read?
PROFESSOR: I am so glad
you asked this question.
The question is, and
what was your name again?
AUDIENCE: Kevin.
PROFESSOR: Kevin.
Kevin asks, gee, if you're
matching from the right
to the left, and you're
doing backtracking,
isn't this going to
be biased towards
the right into the read,
in some sense, right?
Because if the right into
the read doesn't match,
then you're going
to give up, right?
In fact, what we know is
the left end of the read
is the better end of the read.
Because sequences are done five
prime to three prime and thus
typically, the highest quality
scores or the best quality
scores are in the left
hand side of the read.
So do you have any idea about
how you would cope with that?
AUDIENCE: You could just
reverse one of them.
But you'd reverse--
PROFESSOR: Exactly what they do.
They execute the entire genome
and they reverse it and then
they index that.
And so, when they create
what's called a mirror index,
they just reverse
the entire genome,
and now you can
match left to right,
as opposed to right to left.
Pretty cool, huh?
Yeah.
So backtracking, just note that
there are different alignments
that can occur across
different backtracking paths.
And this is not
optimal in any sense.
And to your question
about how you actually
go about picking a
backtracking strategy,
assuming we're matching
from right to left again
for a moment, what you can
do is, if you hit a mismatch,
you backtrack to the lowest
quality based position,
according to PHRED scores.
We talked about
PHRED scores earlier,
which are shown
here on the slide.
And you backtrack there and
you try a different base
and you move forward from there.
So you're assuming
that the read, which
is the query, which is
associated quality scores,
is most suspect where the
quality score is the lowest.
So you backtrack to the right
to the leftmost lowest quality
score.
Now it's a very simple approach.
Right?
And we talked a little
bit about the idea
that you don't necessarily want
to match from the right side
and thus, typically the
parameters to algorithms
like this include,
how many mismatches
are allowed in the first L
bases on the left end, the sum
of the mismatch qualities
you're going to tolerate,
and so forth.
And you'll find that these align
yourself with a lot of switches
that you can set.
And you can consult
with your colleagues
about how to set switches,
because it depends
upon the particular type
of data you're aligning,
the length of the
reads and so forth.
But suffice it to say,
when you're doing this,
typically we create these mirror
indices that actually reverse
the entire genome
and then index it.
So we can either match either
right to left or left to right.
And so for example, if
you have a mirror index,
and you only tolerate
up to two errors,
then you know that
either, you're
going to get the
first half right
in one index or
the mirror index.
And so you can use both indices
in parallel, the forward
and the reverse
index of the genome,
and then get pretty
far into the read
before you have to
start backtracking.
There are all these
sorts of techniques,
shall we say, to
actually overcome some
the limitations of backtracking.
Any questions about
backtracking at all?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it
trivial knowing the BWT
originally to find
the mirror BWT?
Like for example,
PROFESSOR: No, it's not trivial.
AUDIENCE: So it's not
like a simple matrix
transforming [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
Not to my knowledge.
I think you start with the
original genome, you reverse it
and then you compute
the BWT with that.
Right?
That's pretty easy to do.
And Hang was
explaining to me today
how you compute his new
ways of compute BWT, which
don't actually involve
sorting the entire thing.
There are insertion ways of
computing the BWT that are very
[INAUDIBLE], and you could
ask him this question tomorrow
if you care to come.
All right just to give you an
idea on how complex things are,
to build an index
like this, takes,
for the entire
human genome, we're
talking five hours
of compute time
to compute an index to give
you an order of magnitude
time for how to compute the BWT.
the LF checkpoints, and
the suffix array sampling.
Something like that.
So it's really not
too bad to compute
the index of the entire genome.
And to do searches, you
know, we're talking about,
like on a four
processor machine,
we're talking
about maybe upwards
of 100 million rads
per hour to map.
So if you have 200
million reads and you
want to map them to a genome,
or align them as it's sometimes
called, it's going to take
you a couple hours to do it.
So this is sort of the order of
magnitude of the time required
to do these sorts of functions.
And there are a
couple fine points
I wanted to end with today.
The first is we haven't
talked at all about paired,
erred, and read alignment.
In paired read alignment,
you get, for each molecule,
you get two reads.
One starting at the five
prime end on one side, ,
and one starting from the five
prime end on the other side.
So typical read links might
be 100 base pairs on the left
and 100 base pairs on the right.
What is called the insert
size is the total size
of the molecule from five prime
end to five prime end to read.
And the stuff in the
middle is not observed.
We actually don't
know what it is.
And we also don't
know how long it is.
Now when these
libraries are prepared,
size selection is
done, so we get
a rough idea of
what it should be.
We can actually
compute by looking
at where things align on the
genome, what it actually is.
But we don't know absolutely.
If we were able to
strictly control
the length of the
unobserved part, which
is almost impossible to do, then
we would get molecular rulers.
And we would know
exactly down to the base,
whether or not there were
indels between the left read
and the right read when
we did the alignment.
We actually don't
have that today.
The sequencing
instrument actually
identifies the read
pairs in its output.
That's the only way to do this.
So when you get an output
file, like a fast Q file,
from a sequencing
instrument, it will tell you,
for a given molecule,
here's the left read
and here's the right read.
Although left and right are
really sort of misnomers
because there really is
no left and right, right?
This is one end and then
this is the other end.
Typical ways of
processing these paired
reads, first you align
left and right reads.
And they could really
only be oriented
with respect to a
genome sequence where
you say that one has a lower
coordinate than the other one
when you're actually
doing the alignment.
And if one read fails to align
uniquely, then what you can do
is, you know what neighborhood
you're in because you know,
roughly speaking, what
the insert size is,
so you can do Smith Waterman
to actually try and locate
the other read in
that neighborhood.
Or you can tolerate
multiply mapped reads.
One thing that I did not
mention to you explicitly,
is that when you match
the entire query,
and top and bottom are more
than one away from each other,
that means you've got
many places in the genome
that things map.
And thus you may report
all of those locations
or I might report the first one.
So that's one bit of insight
into how to do a map paired
reads.
And these are becoming
very important
because as sequencing
costs go down,
people are doing
more and more paired
and sequencing
because they give you
much more information about the
original library you created
and for certain protocols can
allow you to localize events
in the genome far
more accurately.
Final piece of advice
on considerations
for read alignment.
We talked about the idea that
some reads will map or align
uniquely to the genome
and some will multimap.
You know that the genome is
roughly 50% repeat sequence.
And thus it's likely that if
you have a particular read
molecule, there's
a reasonable chance
that it will map to
multiple locations.
Is there a question here?
No.
OK.
You have to figure out what your
desired mismatch tolerance is
when you're doing alignment
and set the parameters
to your aligner carefully,
after reading the documentation
thoroughly, because
as you could tell,
there's no beautiful
matrix formulation
like there is with a
well established basis
in the literature,
rather it's more ad hoc.
And you need to figure
out what the desired
processing is for paired reads.
So what we've talked
about today is
we started off talking about
library complexity and the idea
that when we get a bunch
of reads from a sequencer,
we can use that collection
of reads to estimate
the complexity of
our original library
and whether or
not something went
wrong in the biological
processing that we were doing.
Assuming it's a
good set of reads,
we need to figure out where
they align to the genome.
So we talked about this idea
of creating a full text minute
size index, which involves
a Burrows-Wheeler transform.
And we saw how we can
compute that and throw away
almost everything else
except for the BWT
itself, the suffix array
checkpoints, and the FM index
checkpoints to be able
to reconstruct this
at a relatively modest increase
in size over the genome
itself and do this very,
very rapid matching,
albeit with more problematic
matching of mismatches.
And then we turned
to the question
of how to deal with those
mismatches with backtracking
and some fine points on
paired end alignment.
So that is the end
of today's lecture.
On Tuesday of next
week, we'll talk
about how to actually construct
a reference genome, which
is a really neat thing
to be able to do, take
a whole bunch of reads, put
the puzzle back together again.
I would encourage you to
make sure you understand
how this indexing
strategy works.
Look at the slides.
Feel free to ask any of us.
Thanks so much for
your attention.
Welcome back.
Have a great weekend.
We'll see you next Tuesday.